same thing like when a man has a woman  that's looking after their kids and  doing all of that being Lord and then he  steps out because he just wants to have  sex isn't that just equally as [ __ ]  it's not the same thing I think the same  would be him funding another woman yes  that's that's more yeah yeah so wouldn't  that be the case if a woman is like how  a man's providing for you and you're  just because you feel neglected in your  team which I think is ridiculous but it  does happen  um wouldn't it be the same kind of  philosophy when a woman's looking after  your kids and being loyalty and cleaning  your house and cooking for you and  because she's not as sexy as she used to  be you're stepping out no do you know I  mean it's the same disrespect no I think  the equivalent is him spending money on  another girl having a full side chick  that he pays her right I think that is